in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
and to talk about our grosses I'm at the
charity in Berlin today with dr. Hazen
back he's the chief physician of the
department for orthopedics osteology and
muscle right thanks for inviting me into
your clinic you're giving a v-line
for a patient with osteoporosis yes it's
not usual in the most of the patients
they receive pills but in this case we
need an injection infusion because she
does not tolerate this pills
Brisbin because of their stomach how do
you diagnose osteoporosis in the first
place in the former times we are
focusing on the bone mineral density
measurement and said well if this value
is minus 2.5 we say austere project
bones today this BMD values are only one
risk factor and we'd need all the other
restrictors as well so other treatments
other diseases the post menopausal
situation and things like that if you
add all this risk factors age gender and
BMD and the risk factors then we can
diagnose osteoporosis only after that
you will start treatment they need
additional restrictors and we calculates
the risk of fractures for the next ten
years
and if the risk is higher than 30% then
we treat with specific treatments women
are more prone to get osteoporosis than
men
why is that yes women have the problem
with the estrogen estrogen starts to act
at the beginning of the ovarian function
and then the women have more bone than
the muscles will impact and this
additional bone is for for lactation and
pregnancy so after this phase of
fertility they are losing their estrogen
and then this goes down fast it was in a
couple of years they lose the additional
bone very fast and they have sometimes
some strange situation with the
structure of the lens and the women have
less muscle forces and the muscles force
is important for the density of the bone
yes the four
strength of the bone the muscle force is
important to have an impact the tempers
strain you say strained as a deformation
of the bone if you increase the muscle
forces that strain is greater and
adapted to the strain to the amount of
strain the bone is formatting or is
losing and this is why men are less
prone to get our super roses because we
do have more muscles yes additionally
additionally that men do get
osteoporosis oh yes men do get us
oppresses a quarter of all Osterberg
patients are males and this is because
of different diseases boundary diseases
diabetes for instance diseases of less
testosterone and things like that
okay we got a viewer question from
Australia imagine Prague wants to know
if there is any medication which can
harden the bone after you develop
osteoporosis most of the medications we
are using today are hardening the bones
because they have one effect is auntie
resort if they stop the loss of the bone
and in the time where they stopped this
last step bone becomes harder because it
is a higher mineralization and on the
other side of course it's and there are
some compounds existing with which you
have osteo anabolic so I mean anabolic
effect on the bones you have more bone
new bone and this is the best way to
treat but we have to inject day by day
like an insulin injection and well for
three years it is okay but not longer
and we got a viewer question concerning
exercise from Klara Diaz is from Brazil
she wants to know if Sport and Exercise
could actually hurt your bones if you
suffer from osteoporosis it depends how
what kind of sports you are doing if you
would make Katrin do or you know or
things like that that is not good for
your bones but you need some exercise
which is asked which are stronger in
strengthening your muscles and the
muscle is very important for stimulates
bones to grow and to become more stiff
and more
and you need dynamic movements so stair
walking or walking in the in the
mountains and here new clinic you
developed a special machine it's called
the Galilean system and what they do
with this machine is simulate sports no
we don't stimulate sports but with
similar simulates walking okay
walking means the the movement for the
walk for walking is very important and
you have to harmonize you know working
activities and with this system you can
organize the activities of the muscles
you can coordinate your muscles again
mostly if you have pain you have this
coordinated muscles so they are working
or together they are working against
each other and with this you have cramp
and that is painful with this system you
can really organize in your coordination
of this muscles but in many health clubs
you can find vibration machines that
claim to do the exact thing so why do I
have to come to your clinic
well vibration is not vibration and this
is not the effect it's not to have a
vibrating system it is an effect that
you have to coordinate muscles that is a
sight alternative movement of this of
this board and that is the principle
basic on this intervention and I can't
just do it with a walk yes if you want
to walk you have to go walk very fast
and I have to read up to a sequential
power walking that means not well sticks
but without sticks that you go very fast
for 100 meters and then you go slowly
for next next 100 meters and then you
can work very fast again so this is very
effective on muscle for a massive force
on muscle power let's talk a bit about
nutrition or first about the supplement
of parts of nutrition about vitamin D
everybody's talking always about vitamin
D what role does it play in osteoporosis
vitamin D is really very important that
is I've but I think this hype is of
interest and important because what
windy deficiency is has an effect on a
kind of different organ organ systems
first
you need vitamin D for the resort
of castle ii the muscles need vitamin D
because there are a lot of vitamin D
receptors in the muscles and therefore
if you have less vitamin D you're a weak
weak muscles and the risk of fall is
increasing with that and all other
different organs have thousands and
millions of vitamin E receptors and
therefore vitamin E is important for not
only bone and muscle but for other
organs as well so you know what about
the role of general nutrition about
calcium levels of drinking milk yes it's
very important to take care that you
have enough calcium per day milk milk
products are very important
of course but if you are having lactose
intolerance or some diseases or short
bowel then you need additional calcium
and this additional class we should not
take biofilm you should take it by
mineral water or by selecting your foods
so you need about 1,000 milligrams per
day and this is very easy to take so
only in specific cases you have to add
some calcium pills but this is only
specific diseases a youth or black
Svendsen linked from Iceland wants to
know if drinking coffee could harm your
bones and he's drinking 5 big cups of
coffee per day 4 to 5 cups of coffee per
day I think it's not really the problem
the Sun the scientific discussion is not
finalized at least because there are
some studies we share well there has may
be risk to have a loss of months or not
so at least I think if you need this
coffee drink it what about the different
counts and levels in Jesus and in milk
Artemisia Cardenas from Greece wants to
know if cow milk is comparable to goat
milk for instance
Cattell is the calcium content I think
these different milks also very
comparable so if somebody prefers a
sheep milk or goat milk I think that is
very good so at least it is important
not only for the calcium it is important
for the proteins as well thanks so much
for inviting me today into a clinic
octave has max
you